[Music]
d
oh oh you damn right that's booze that's
me it's in the
title Not Gon to dance around it
tonight oh that's good
stuff hi everybody
hope you're all doing well
um my channeling Ursa tonight
darling every
night ah needing something strong not
not really it is a specific brand of me
but the problem is there's no point in
me recommending it because this was a
small local meery she literally made the
stuff in her garage and she has retired
from meat making but this was sticky
Paws metery in uh where was she Milton
she was in Milton
Vermont oh so
good I've got I've got this and I've got
one other bottle this is this is mold
over this is the mold
me which was my favorite that she did
all her stuff was good so I've got this
and I've got one more
bottle I'm going to be so sad when this
is
gone I'm I'm dragging out working my way
through these bottles partly in the Hope
partly in the
hope that she'll decide to start making
it again and I can stock up we'll
see that is correct goer support your
local meery or cidery or Winery or
Brewery if that's your jam I guess you
know unless they're
[__] I did unfortunately learned
that about a cidery
um uh that uh that I used to drink their
stuff um and run by a bunch of jackasses
so until the ownership change hands I
will not be drinking citizen cider and I
would encourage other people to um not
drink it
either
ah and I did look into it like legit it
it kind of blew up on Reddit and I kind
of hoped in the back of my mind
selfishly that it would just turn out to
be like some overblown rumor mill stuff
like no no I've like I know people who
um I know in trust and aren't just rumor
mongers who actually have a very clear
idea of what specifically was going on
it's like oh well
crap oh well
H I'll be careful going through icy snow
Miss Wicked Wolf and no I don't wear a
sleep
mask so good it's
so
good uh but yes I I I this this cup is
not nothing but me I added it to um
warmed up traditional apple cider
um
oh oh that's
good uh Southern Middle Tennessee is
only recently thought out from the ice o
yikes so happy to see everyone today
been a couple of rough weeks I'm sorry
to hear that that
Amber hope that things get better Oh
Captain
Lunar coming in with the Super Chat U
your reminder that while I will try and
keep up with the chat the only thing
that guarantees interaction is a Super
Chat which also gets you the heart of
appreciation well that's not the only
thing also if you're in the patreon
exclusive Discord but questions on that
are closed if you missed the window
already settle a
debate okay for sure could a Batman if
he had all his abilities and texts from
the com from the comics take a major
dent out of human trafficking
IRL yes because Batman is super
overpowered in both his deductive uh
abilities and also his resources uh in
the comics
which he shouldn't be but he is because
he's on the Justice League and most of
the members of the Justice League have
like legitimate actual superpowers so
since they weren't going to give him
actual superpowers they just kept
jacking up his resources more and more
and more so he has to have resources and
um tactical and deductive abilities that
are Beyond literally everybody else so
that he can be as useful as all the
superpowered people so yeah yeah you
probably
could now the the thing is it's a
question of scope if if the person
you're arguing with mainly thinks of
Batman specifically in his Gotham
operations then no no I could see why
someone would argue no because
like he he can't even stop the local
Asylum from being the easiest place to
break out of in the freaking world like
how's he going to stop trafficking but
you need to remember you go to a planez
threat he's going to bust out the
planetz resources and he has
them ah
pin message actually working this time
that's good that's good oh hey John good
to see you always nice to see you pop
in and of course of course hi to
everybody I didn't I didn't like do the
greetings too much at the beginning I I
was busy
whistling um any Doctor Who cons that
are worth attending if you live in the
middle of the US uh anyway wanted to go
to one um there's one uh there's one
that's in I think it's Chicago hold
on yeah uh Chicago
Tardis
um yeah which I've never been to so I
can't personally vouch for that one but
if you're not uh um if you're not
traveling um out out of the Midwest
that's probably going to be your best
bet um I will be going to Gala Fray 1
next month very excited for that that'll
be my third time
going uh Garfield Hello Kitty or Pusheen
I mean depends
on excuse me depends on what I'm there
for if we're just going aesthetic
Pusheen Hello Kitty Garfield if I'm
actually going to engage with it
Garfield if I get to dictate where the
cut off is like Garfield up to 94 but
like nothing
later um what's your superpower I'm rich
Best Line in any SN film ever I don't
know I'm not sure it's better than this
is
Spa but it's pretty
good like people mocked that line but
it's it's kind of
true uh uh there's a Victorian Arrow
Street in my my town called Old Road how
original it never occurred to me uh but
wouldn't that name have made no sense
when it was built in the 1880s well
presumably at the time that well okay
let's back up two things we're assuming
that it hasn't been renamed in more
recent times so assuming that that is
not the case and it was originally
called Old Road when it was built then
it was probably like an original already
ground in trail like some kind of um of
dirt road that like I don't
know um the freaking Romans marched up
and down or something like it it could
still have been a pre-existing path
which would you know make it still kind
of make it the old
road if you were the showrunner of
Doctor Who what ideas would you have for
a series people ask me that from time to
time and I don't know how to answer it
for the same reason I'm bad at
speculation I like I don't have that job
and it's very hard even if I try to get
my
um um my brain to devote its creative
energies to something that I know
nothing will come of it like me thinking
about here's what I would do is like
literally just it would just be for the
sake of that exercise and my brain
doesn't really let me funnel my creative
energies in that kind of direction if I
would like to think if I actually got
the gig I would have um ideas or if like
I don't know badwolf production said hey
put together a pitch deck oh I'd put
something together but like for casual
questions unfortunately my brain won't
relax its grip on the on the whole idea
of like this is not a good use of your
energy stop
it my brain holds me hostage sometimes
I'm trying to get a negotiator in but
it's uh it's tough
going read an article about the tomb of
Hanah
cour uh
courtoy supposedly holds a a time
machine okay sounds like a premise for a
Doctor Who episode yeah I'd say that's a
solid enough premise just watch perfect
blue for the first time and it blew me
away have you seen a buite any chance
not only have I seen it I own it I also
haven't seen it in 20 years because it's
one of those movies that I bought
because it because I got it like
secondhand like five bucks on DVD uh and
I was like oh I'll watch that again and
I never have I still
keep it um because like I will watch I
will rewatch it again I
remember I remember being slightly let
down by some of the explanations that
come in the third act um basically I was
I was a little bit let down that there
was as much explanation as there was I
kind of would have preferred less which
is kind of what Black Swan did with the
concept which was one of the things I
appreciated about that movie um it's
it's good though it it is good I have
seen it it's
good
uh least worst SN film
I
I I still like 300 I own that movie I
have watched it more than once I will
probably watch it again in future it's
is it problematic as hell uh from any
kind of historical or political analysis
oh hell yeah absolutely I will not
defend it from that kind of criticism at
all but I think it also like as a
filmmaker plays to all of his strengths
and very few of his
weaknesses
um what would your current four things
Doctor Who should never do be I'm not
sure I could make that video now cuz the
thing is given that we have had
instances of being done that I just I
unat thought were bad ideas and
sometimes them working out I'm not sure
I could come up with a list I'd be
comfortable with
because this is kind of me giving leeway
to other creatives like somebody can
think of a way to do this that you can't
think of that could actually make it
work which is literally what happened
with the 14th doctor that's a bad idea
by generation's a bad idea and they both
worked for me because they were executed
really well so I'm not even sure sure I
I would have it in me to make a a
version of that video
now when are you going to react to your
most popular video given that it's
literally a month
old uh probably never I don't think
there'd be anything interesting for me
reacting to my my current most viewed
video
uh how much Doctor Who do you own
physically I own
series 1 through
12 and power of the
doctor
I don't have flux that might be the
first modern arow one that I skip I have
a smattering of classic um like I have
the entire key to Time season uh and
I've got tombs of the Cybermen
remembrance of the
dox
um Time Warrior uh doll like invasion of
Earth I think I've got some others I've
got the dominators because that was the
easiest way to get it when I got
commissioned it because I found it cheap
and I wasn't subscribed to bit box at
the
time that might be all that I
have physically not sure I have to
check perfect blue is the one Darren
aronowski keeps ripping off right funny
thing about that uh ER he actually
bought the adaptation rights before
making Black Swan even though Black Swan
isn't really an adaptation of perfect
blue but he wanted to recreate some of
those images very specifically and it
would have been
plagiarism uh or at least very shady for
him to do so uh with multiple
shots um so even though Black Swan is
not an adaptation of perfect blue he
bought the um the Remake rights
basically for the sake of his own
conscience to be like look I'm not
adapting the story but I am adapting the
mood and some very specific visuals and
I want it to be okay so that I feel like
ripping off might might be a little
harsh under those
circumstances
uh my landlord texted me he's going to
raise the rent they always are if you
get a text from a landlord it's never
good
news um Captain Lunar coming in
again with the Super Chat you are given
a choice of having one mythology being
real and fairly accurate as can be which
do you pick and
why
oh if you'll allow me the leeway of
accepting folklore as mythology than I
would say Celtic Fay
folklore um if only because it deals the
least with Gods who can literally decide
to mess with anybody anywhere any time
for any or no reason and a bit more of
just be really really careful around
these kinds of spaces and these kinds of
creatures which I feel like is a much
more like I don't think there's any
version uh at least mythologies that I
know well enough like maybe there is but
no mythology that I'm aware of would
actually be a comfortable place for
people to live but I feel like you you'd
have better
odds in a world with Celtic Fay um than
you would with you know Greek or Norse
or Egyptian or what have
you I'm not going to be on here very
long but I'm currently dealing with a
mouth infection ooh yeah antibiotics are
tiring me out oh well I hope that clears
up
soon I have to Neo shate with my brain
all the time Ain't it
Fun uh if you could pick only one series
of new who to watch for the rest of your
life what would it be series 10 piece of
cake uh have you done a best companion
exits ranking I have it's uh a couple
years old now so it's it's not current
but yes I have done that one uh it's one
of the ones that'll probably need to be
Revisited
eventually as I'm pursuing my generative
writing project I'm wondering when is
your best time to write sledit when you
are
writing um if you mean time of the
day whenever I whenever I actually kick
my my ass hard enough to
start
um yeah I I don't have it's daylight
hours that that much is probably true I
have a hard time wrangling my creative
brain in the
dark sometimes I can but often when the
Sun goes down my brain's like cool we're
done for the day uh other than
that that's that's about all I've
got uh let's
see about four worst things Doctor Who
has done uh it would be tricky not to
have that just degenerate
into uh a four worst episodes
thing
maybe I don't
know I I'm less inclined to do the
purely negative Doctor Who Um ranking
videos I mean I I still will from time
to time I actually have an idea that I'm
working on that I am going to break up
into a best of and worst of list because
I consider doing like a full ranking of
the of a certain kind of episode I'm not
going to say what it is because not far
enough along in the project yet though
caroan knows what I'm talking about hey
Meg um so I feel like full rankings are
generally what I tend to like better
because it allows me to not stay in a
holy negative space while still
addressing the negative stuff like let's
start with the bad stuff and then get to
the good stuff the purely negative lists
are getting
harder
um just because of where I'm at in
general and the kind of stuff that I'd
rather be making like I said it'll still
happen every now and then
but I I I don't know it's not a bad idea
but I don't know it just it just it
doesn't sit right
somehow
uh nobody knows today the UK kind of
warmed up with my house is heating on I
realize it's the first time I've been
hot since summer enjoy it I
guess
uh oh how how is your demanding little
dog today Meg by the
way
uh tomorrow's Phil Lamar and Kristen
Sha's
birthdays I'm good on them have I
finished the ghost of Molly McGee
I don't
no I don't think
so kiddo and I will probably get back to
that but um we've shifted to other stuff
for the time being I forgot more stuff
came out h I literally
forgot
um what's the worst TV episode you've
watched out of any TV
show
uh I'm still gonna say it's the original
Dexter series finale from
season
eight they got to eight right yeah they
did they got to eight I think yeah they
did yeah they got to eight
um the thing about that though is to
appreciate why it's so bad you have to
have watched the rest of Dexter because
it's one of those things that if you
were to watch it in isolation you'd be
like well it's not great but is this
really the worst thing it's so bad
because of how it it squanders and
misunderstands and fails to just be
anything that the show has been up to
that point um
so with proper context
that one if you're talking about like
worst episode of a TV show that you can
watch in isolation and go wow that's a
real bad episode of TV I don't know
probably something I've never
watched have I seen any of the has been
Hotel uh not yet leis I will I'm going
to but I haven't
yet ver is a morning person Say It Ain't
So that is not what I said Dharma that
is not what I said at all don't don't
you put those words in my mouth holy
[Laughter]
cow
H we have another brain that works very
well in the dark
H damn
it damn it John
he's not
[Laughter]
[Music]
wrong is there any piece of media you
would like to see Doctor Who do a
crossover with in the comics nope not
really do you think huie and horor might
be an interesting route like the doctor
squaring off against pin head no if they
wanted to have him take on more of
crafty and Cosmic horror stuff which you
can do without necessarily even having
it to tie directly into the cthulu
Mythos that I'd be up
for but in the
um in the
multiversal
and oversaturated over franchised and
entertainment environment we currently
live in uh the idea of crossovers don't
excite me they exhaust me I'm I'm like
there's a video game where you could be
Scooby-Doo or Arya
Stark like my response to crossovers at
this point is yeah sure that might as
well happen I guess because they're not
special anymore they're not a rarity
anymore it's not like oh wow I never
thought I'd see that like at this point
I assume I'll see everything because
eventually everybody will buy up
everybody until we
have one Omni corpor a super mega globo
Tech and you
know it'll all be
meaningless I saw David Tenant in MC
Beth on Friday which uh doctor would you
like to see on the stage H eckl's been
doing a lot of stage stuff lately I bet
he'd be
good are you in control of your drivve
and creativity or is it more like bumps
on the road where suddenly uh you can do
stuff
I have to work with my ADHD and part of
that
is um not trying to force control that I
don't have um sometimes I I have to do
that like if something like if this has
to get done today I can force it but uh
on an Ideal work day I roll with the
general direction my brain already wants
to go so maybe I woke up thinking this
is what I'd prefer to do today but I
can't Wrangle my brain to do that so
it's like okay can I can I get it is
there anything that I can point it at
that would still be productive so
largely I have to cow to to where my
brain goes um I will like sort
of bully it into uh into a certain area
now and then when I really need to but I
really try not to have that be a regular
[Music]
basis
which uh classic Who Doctor are you the
closest to finishing now well I finished
six I I already finished six so he's
done
um after that seven I'm the closest to
finishing
seven yeah it's seven it's five I got
the same number of things left for three
and two although not really CU there's
still some two stuff that hasn't
been um animated yet so uh guess two is
a little bit closer than three than one
then four cuz four has a lot a lot a lot
a
lot what am I looking forward to most of
galif fray
one just the just the feel of it I just
like being with a group of people who
tend to go to that thing uh I'm on a
panel as well that'll be fun um but like
it it's the entirety of the experience
it's being around that group of people
that group of dedicated fans
and it's it's just nice it's nice like
to to go to a convention dedicated to
one thing like that is where and like
I've had conversation with people who
are obviously not super thrilled with
the state of the show you know at the
time I was there but they were still
happy to be there excited to be there
and and had positivity even if they
didn't like the current state of the
show which was something that we often
disagreed on but like everyone's there
to have fun and they do and it's
great what's my take on the Millie
Gibson drama I literally put up a video
earlier today Amelia so I will not be
addressing that um on stream CU already
did
it amphibia or Owl House owl
house
uh the dog is well she did all of her
business ate all of her dinner so I'm
trying to count those as wins currently
huffing and puffing at the door du to
our neighbors uh she's got to get over
that am I aware of the hasb been Hotel
music video
controversy no is it actually a
controversy worth anything or is it just
just the normal
nonsense there's already been a doctor
who Lovecraft crossover Audio Drama I
believe yeah i' I'd buy
that
uh it's a great M I leave for Disney on
Thursday Happy
Trails um is it weird to like your body
as a person with social anxiety I've
been told by other people it's weird I
don't have that no I don't think so I
mean it might be uncommon but I don't
think that's the same as weird it's
probably along the same lines as being
neurod Divergent and not having insomnia
hey hi how you doing um but like that's
not a requirement for having anxiety
they like it's a ven diagram with a lot
of crossover you know having anxiety
about your own personal opinion and
general social anxiety but one is not a
requirement M for the other it's not uh
con it's not um what's the word I'm I'm
looking
for it's not
um compulsory to the condition of social
anxiety Discord Thank You Caroline for
that reminder uh give me just a second
I'm just going to check check a couple
of things here real quick oh talk to you
later
John
um okay so I'm GNA pop over to the
Council of Geeks Discord and take a look
at the questions there reminder that is
a patreon exclusive perk um so if you
want access to that you need to go to
the patreon but in any case let me get
through these and I'll be back to the
main chat and as soon as I deal with
these you may have already addressed
this by the time you check the Discord
but thoughts on Greta Gerwig and Margo
Robbie not getting nominated for Barbie
for the Academy Awards gret in
particular feels like a bit of a snub
with the movie getting a best picture
nod um no I don't have too many thoughts
on margar Robbie did surprise me that
one did actually surprise me except that
I kind of think that I'm surprised the
the Oscar nominations haven't come up as
a topic in the chat yet or if they did I
missed it um I'm a little bit surprised
um by her by um margar Robbie not being
um nominated but when I think about it I
think the academy is a little bit
reluctant to give Barbie as many
nominations as they have and I think
there's a very specific reason for that
I think in another year they might have
really wanted to buoy it up because like
it gives them the chance to award
something that's very popular which they
don't often get the chance to do but the
thing is this year there's Oppenheimer
which was also very popular and they'
probably wanted to award
um Christopher Nolan something for a
while the only other time he got
nominated for director was when he did
Dunkirk Oscars the Oscars love
historicals and they love biopics like
the safe money is on Oppenheimer and on
Christopher Nolan to win I don't
consider Greta Gerwig to be nearly as
much of a snub for two reasons one she's
also nominated for the screenplay along
with with no bomback and two there's
going to be at least five notable snubs
because there's 10 nominees for Best
Picture and only five nominees for best
director so like it's not that odd that
she got a snub even though the picture
got nominated that happens literally
half the time these days with just the
way that it's set up that having been
said I did check um there has only been
one year in the history of the Oscars
where more than one woman was
nominated so
you know that was 2020 for the record uh
would have been nice if they could have
nominated more than one woman uh I
forget who did get the nomination but
like I I haven't seen like 90% of the
films that got major nominations
so is it true that Taco Bell opening up
is like Christmas and New Year's in
urban Vermont first of all what the hell
is urban
Vermont what what what is that even even
mean urban Vermont so
Burlington Burlington's the only area in
Vermont that I would consider Urban at
all um and also no so double
no uh were candles actually good enough
for grandma or did she use a lantern I
don't know she's not around for me to
ask her anymore why is a raven like a
writing
desk no one
knows
uh do you think there are any Sci-Fi
series or franchises that go against the
tropes or cliches that seem to be all
too frequent like dune's feudal Future
For All Mankind the expanses exploited
of capitalism in space or just the
borderline outright nihilism of the
Cyber Punk genre
um series and franchises
no I think most most stuff that really
breaks convention that fits into sci-fi
is stuff that is
unfranchise like Eternal Sunshine of the
Spotless Mind is a sci-fi movie you
wouldn't think of it as one cuz
what because it because it lacks almost
all the conventions and all the tropes
but you franchise that so major series
of franchises I mean there might be one
out there I can't think of
one any thoughts on Noah KH and what is
stick season as in and I love Vermont
but is the season of the sticks okay um
I don't have any thoughts on Noah Kong
because I literally only found out who
he was today and the only reason the
only reason I know who he is is because
his song was I think number two one of
his songs was number two on Todd and the
Shadows um video on the 10 best songs of
2023 that came out earlier today and I
watched that was watching that was
literally the first time I'd ever heard
of him so this is now now the second but
I can't explain stick season stick
season is basically the back half of
fall because you know you think fall in
Vermont and you think oh the gorgeous
colors and yes we do have that but Peak
uh meaning Peak color and Vermont is two
weeks tops and then all the leaves fall
off and it sticks so the period of time
between when all the leaves have fallen
off the tree and the first snow that's
stick season
uh in terms of your recent reaction
video to yourself what do you think is
the biggest change in terms of delivery
not presentation I.E you seem much more
measured now in my opinion um I think
I'm a far less prone to
um uh hyperbole that I was I I still
like even looking back at some of the
old stuff I still don't think I was
nearly as bad as like a lot of creators
even now still are in terms of like
really leaning into the anger or like
presenting it you know in a in you know
louder and more frustrated than I
actually was I didn't like I did do that
a little but I didn't do it to the
extreme that a lot of folks do but I did
it a little and I don't really do that
at all anymore just
because that's exhausting and draining
not
fun so I don't know to me that feels
like the biggest change if I go off on
something if if I go on a rant it's CA I
actually care I don't force that stuff
it's because I actually need to get
these thoughts out of my head and I'm
probably
annoyed if someone uh visits the US what
is one fast food chain to avoid above
all others other than Chick-fil-A and
one that is actually
okay I mean the one I'm going to say to
avoid is not for the reasons you're kind
of implying which is like oh it's so bad
um but avoid McDonald's because you if
you're visiting the US you probably have
a McDonald's where you're at odds are
pretty good so
like skip that one do something else as
a as for ones that are actually okay
sticking like with genuine fast food um
as opposed to like family restaurants
and what you know other other franchises
oh actually you know what I suppose I
suppose it does classify as um fast food
skip
Subway
like subway is not awful but like
it's just a
sandwich you you watch them make a
sandwich it's fine I eat subway now and
then but like it's not an experience I'd
recommend to
anybody other than that as opposed to
one that like is actually okay I don't
know I think most fast food is okay if
you're in the mood for it the problem is
you need to try it at some point to find
out if it's something you'll ever be in
the mood for like a lot of people slam
Taco Bell I'll get Taco Bell now and
then not often but I don't know every 3
four months get a light hankering go you
know
what I I I could go for some cheap
ground beef I don't know it happens it's
I mean like I think all of them are
almost all of them are okay like fast
food is okay that's the N that's the
nature of fast food you trade quality
for
Speed
okay back in the 1980s my mother was a
young teacher at an inner city uh
elementary school they had this one
signed female at Birth student who
always came to school dressed in the
masculine school uniform the staff kind
of treated them as a sort of pseudo boy
uh like they even let them go with the
boys during PE when they reached um year
seven which is 11 years old uh their dad
started forcing them to go to school in
a pink coat and school uniform dress
what do you think is the ideal way to
handle that as an affirming teacher um
unfortunately you you you kind of can't
well in the US you you can't um I don't
know what the rules are in the UK and
teachers over there so I I can't speak
um to anything like that but like the
simple truth is is that the best you can
do um is just to be
like offer whatever affirmations are not
in contradiction to um the stated
desires of the
parent like and that's probably not
going to be much like at best if they
have an preferred name or um I mean
probably wasn't the case with the
situation you're talking about because
that was the 80s but like they have a
preferred name like maybe try and use
that but even that these days depending
on what state you're teaching in you can
get in trouble for that too it's there
aren't there there isn't a
lot there especially at at this point
and in a lot of areas in the US what few
things you kind of could do to be
supportive have actually been made so
doing it might cost you your job
so find out what the rules are in your
local area and figure out from there why
do you think right Wingers can't see
Trump seems like a prick they know he's
a prick they know they here's a
fundamental thing you need to understand
about Trump the people who genuinely
like him and I mean genuinely like him
not just the people who are like well
I'm going to vote for him because I'll
never vote for a Democrat and they'll
just vote for whoever the hell even
though they say I wouldn't vote for
Trump yeah you freaking will but setting
those people aside the people who
genuinely love Trump the fact that he's
an [__] is not a bug gets a feature
they like that about him they like that
he pisses off the left they like that he
just Flatout says horrible things they
either think it's funny or it's somehow
a sign of power or they themselves are
[__] and you tend to gravitate
towards someone that you relate to and
is the most like
you Trump being an absolute garbage fire
of a human being is not a bug it's a
feature to the people who again
genuinely like
him I suspect that most of the people
who will vote for him but like would
prefer somebody else with the candidate
probably don't like that about him but
they're still going to freaking vote for
him so it doesn't
matter there's a bit in one of the two
culture stories I want um to review
that's not to hint to get to the my sare
appreciate it um we're an outsider to
the culture ask a culture citizen uh
this this is uh the series of books by
ianm banks for contexts for folks if she
feels lucky to live there she tells him
that the culture's education system
tries to install and understand
understanding that they're intensely
lucky But ultimately it's hard not to
just view getting to do whatever you
want all the time as the norm when it's
all you've ever known do you think
that's an accurate view of human nature
I.E um whatever you're most used to will
seem the norm even if we know it's not
yeah yeah I mean that's just an
extrapolation to living in a first world
country I live in a country where I
reliably have clean water and heat and
access to
food and while I understand
intellectually that I am lucky to have
that and there are many many many places
in the world that
don't this still feels normal to me even
though I
know it is not for many many many many
people it's just an extrapolation of
what we already have as a lot of sci-fi
is would you ever consider doing a
reaction to to one of your own reaction
videos reaction deception oh
God that very notion kind of breaks my
brain partially because the results will
be like at minimum two hours because the
reaction videos are already by their
nature longer than the original video so
it just get longer every time eventually
I'd be doing like a 24-hour Marathon
reacting to my reaction to my reaction
to my reaction to my original
video somebody have to pay me for
that are there any classic Who villains
you'd like to see brought back I mean
Omega is still the big one in my mind I
keep hearing that there's some issues
with the rights for him fans say that
I've never seen anybody provide me uh
receipts for why that is the case so I
think that's just fan
assumption um do you have any major
Comfort movies you always go back
to yes and
no I don't rewatch movies much anymore
because if I'm going to sit down and
watch a
movie
my my brain that reminds me of how
behind I am on work kind of goes hey um
you you need to uh be if you're going to
watch something you need to watch
something that you uh are supposed to be
doing a review
on um so really the only time I ever
watch something that I've seen before is
if I'm watching it with somebody else
who maybe hasn't seen it before or they
wanted to rewatch it and then it's like
oh well I I can shut up that part of my
brain that says you should be watching
something you should be doing a review
on by going I'm not watching it for me
I'm watching it with this person to
experience it with this person and let
me just have this experience my brain
will actually let me do that but like my
major Comfort movies used to be um stuff
like the original Ghostbusters Kung Fu
Panda um how to train a dragon the first
too but I haven't rewatched any of these
things in years cuz just sitting down to
watch a comfort
movie it does that's not really my life
anymore okay I am back to the to the
main chat oh we got super chats in
Supreme Omega thank you kindly on
Indiana Jones I feel Raiders didn't need
any sequels the first film had such a
perfect light was the first film such a
perfect lightning in a bottle the series
does have an Empire level sequel
[Music]
um
I'm I'm not going to fully agree with
that um I'd say the thing there is
that I think the nature of Indiana Jones
lends itself to the um James Bond style
franchise let's see Indy's next
adventure which is more or less what the
franch has been
um so I think comparing it to like an
Empire I assume you mean Empire Strikes
Back level sequel it was never going to
have that because the reason Empire
lands the way it does is because it's
literally continuing the story Indiana
Jones isn't built for that kind of
sequel at all but he is built for a
let's see one of his other Adventures
kind of sequels now were they all good
no Temple of Doom I'm sorry SU
sucks it
sucks a couple of good bits but overall
that's that's not a good movie
um and Crystal Skull is got a lot of
problems but
um I think they made the kind of sequels
that Mak sense for Indiana Jones and I
don't really have a problem with them
existing I wish their batting average
was better but I love Last Crusade
that's a great movie I ever heard of the
movie burles starring Sharon Christine
of course I've heard of it and no I
haven't seen it and no I won't unless
somebody pays
me Last Crusade is probably the best
Indie sequel no it
is I I don't know I don't know why you
put um
probably in front of that like it is I
don't know who would debate that I guess
some people really like Temple of Doom I
don't know why I really don't know why
other than
Nostalgia Nostalgia is
powerful oh
well
oh
well you know they could do Jones like
Bond or like who uh what if they just
cast a new Jones instead of passing the
torch I there was rumors of that I think
they missed their window on that that's
not to say they won't try at some point
but I think the window for doing that
would have been after Last
Crusade um but instead they did Crystal
Skull and kind of really solidified no
it's uh it's Harrison for no matter how
old he is um I think it'd be a lot
harder for them to to sell
that uh Suggs with a box thank you very
much for the Super Chat how are you by
the way love the hair thank you I
refreshed the color earlier today which
is actually why I'm in this particular
top I had to be sure that I wor
something that um was low enough that if
if there was any remaining wetness on
this it wouldn't stain in a
shirt um and then I had to be careful on
how I frame the shot because if
I had this up a little too high like
say uh
roundabout
there
I look like I'm just sitting here
topless which I'm not
so there we
go uh Andrew dykens thank you very much
for the Super Chat greatly appreciated
oh and uh cloak the librarian thank you
for the membership I missed that earlier
thank you very much um just watch your
reaction into your old video Amazing by
the way but I was wondering how weird
was it watching your previous
regeneration much love not as weird as
you'd think partially because I don't
have the level of dysphoria that a lot
of trans people do so like it's not um
it's not like oh God like it's a little
weird um but it's it's not this is all
tilted now hang on it's not like um it's
not dysphoria inducing or anything like
that so it's just kind of like oh yeah
that was me back then wasn't it I like I
suspect it probably for me Falls
somewhere between the
standard level of weird that I think
most creators looking at something that
old that they made would
feel it's between that and the kind of
weird that most trans people probably
feel looking at their pre-transition
self it's in the middle it's weirder
than I think is the standard base level
weird for most creators he can't throw
little stuff but it's not quite as weird
is I think it is for most trans people
to um to see their pre-transition self
celebrated three months with my
girlfriend yesterday
congratulations we saw the new Mean
Girls we both thought it was a lot of
fun despite some negative comments we
had seen beforehand I mean I don't plan
to see it I'm just not I don't really I
don't really like this whole movie to
Stage musical to movie again pipeline
that uh the producers started although
like producers technically did it first
I'm not sure they're entirely to blame
um because it didn't really pick up as a
trend until more recent like as a more
ongoing thing yeah I don't
know uh fun funny it's uh it's not a
dress it is just a
top yep no no bottom here just a
I see a bowler hat you do see a bowler
hat I I haven't put this back up in my
closet yet I wore this or no I didn't
wear this I got this down thinking I
might wear it um last month when I was
on the um the charity live reading of A
Christmas Carol um this thing's falling
apart though like the edge is all frayed
the the interior needs to be fixed I I
got to I gotta I got to get in touch
with my local habiter and get that thing
fixed
uh I really hope my question about the
right way to refer to your past self
didn't come across his route it didn't
like I it it throws a lot of people off
um the way I am very C casual about my
own um past masculinity because a a lot
of trans people are a lot more um you
know distancing and and dysphoric about
it so like remember I'm not the template
you should use for anybody I'm atypical
like partially based on the fact that I
am not actually a transwoman I am trans
feminine certainly I am gender fluid but
I'm not actually a transwoman um I I
don't identify as such at this time
Terra staller good to see you thank you
for the Super Chat hey bear question on
your self- review I noticed you know you
used he him for your past self do you
consider yourself an exception to the
retroactively applied pronouns
rule no but so uh I guess to explain
context for
um for for just uh for for anybody who
like isn't sure what we're talking about
so as a general rule of thumb when
talking to when talking to or about any
trans person you should refer to them
with their current preferred pronouns
even if uh as well as current preferred
name even if you are going to be
referring to something that happened to
them pre-transition so like if you grew
up with someone who is now transitioned
but like you grew up together as kids
and they were the other gender even if
you talk about when you were kids
together best practice is to refer to
back then with the name and pronouns
they use now that is best practice as a
rule so the question was do I do I
consider myself an acception to that
rule since during my uh my video where I
reacted to my own contact I referred to
the person I was seeing as him
so no I don't think I'm an exception to
that rule but here's the
thing and I this is weird and esoteric
and keep in mind human beings are not
machines we are not uh a a rigid um
conglomeration of rules that cannot be
bent and or broken it must be followed
at all times and must be 100% consistent
so the reality is is that me referring
to my past self as him wasn't something
that I thought about before I said it I
said it because it's what felt right to
say actually looking at that face
looking at that face knowing that at the
time I still was using he him as uh Ana
as a a I think still primary at that
point um
pronoun
I it it's just what came out of my mouth
and it felt okay I think I'd be a lot
less comfortable hearing somebody
else refer to earlier
content um either pre-transition or pre-
dropping the masculine pronoun because
keep in mind I came out in 2008 I didn't
drop the masculine pronoun for a couple
years after after that um and at this
point it's she they but uh the the thing
is like I I I don't I don't think I'd be
comfortable with anyone else doing it
it's just kind of what happened in the
moment cuz like I I feel kind of
disconnected from the person that I was
at at the time anyway so for me it just
like felt like putting natural distance
um but I I don't think I don't want to
say that I'm an exception because I
don't think I'd be okay with somebody
else doing it
um so just chalk it up to the
inconsistency of human beings that I did
it to myself and was obviously okay with
that that having been said
reminder my birth name Nathaniel it's
not a dead name you can call me that
generally I go by ver these days it's
matches my presentation most of the time
and it just seemed uh easier and made
more sense to put everything under a
single uh creative uh umbrella I think
the only thing I intend to continue to
still put out under Nathaniel is my
fantasy series
but um Nathaniel is not a dead name but
I would still ask even if you are
calling me Nathaniel to use she or they
pronouns so I think that covers
everything ah Supreme Omega back
again on Temple of Doom do you feel the
film would have been better if Willie
was removed cuz she had nothing could
have been just Indian Short
Round it would have
helped there'd still be a lot of
problems
CA Oh
Boy there there there's
some there's some choices made in the uh
in the depictions of non-white people uh
in that movie and it's and even with
Willie remove just as a whole just a
mean-spirited movie I I've said in the
past like you can really tell it was
made by a couple of guys going through
divorces it really has that energy
removing Willie would help but not
enough to save
it uh Banks wrote an essay about the
culture that mentioned the fact that
their education system teaches them
their privilege they put a segment in
one of his books about why that not
work then put second why that not work I
mean that's that's a healthy thing for
him to
examine um what's my favorite werewolf
movie I don't know probably dog soldiers
there aren't that many great werewolf
movies uh if we're being
honest uh let's
see uh no Matt my kid has never called
me mom my my kid calls me Dad and always
has and always will um now for what I'm
for what I'm about to say this is true
of me me alone do not take this as a
metric or guideline to apply to any
other trans people of any kind unless
they say something similar to what I'm
about to say but for me dad is not an
especially gendered term and I don't
just mean like the fact that a woman can
be
Daddy which is true but
um
excuse me for me Dad's dad's the job dad
is the title and that's the nature of
the relationship that I have with my kid
and it's always going to be the
relationship that I have with my kid I'm
not my kid's
mom I like I'm just not my kid has a
mother who's around it is a great parent
I'm dad I mean I just am and again my
relatively low amount of dysphoria and
um probably makes that an easier call
for me most transparents that I know
have preferred that their kids start to
refer to them with the parental term
that the general understanding of its
gender best matches their current um
identity that is that has been my uh
observation of being true for most trans
people it's not true of me in
particular excuse
me we are going to wrap it up in just a
minute
Here Andrew
dykens thank you very much for the Super
Chat you ref friend yourself as he him
seemed very doctor likee are you the
doctor if so where are we going what
companions would you like to be your
companion well you can't make that call
in advance can you
you have to
um you have to feel it out you have to
see who you run into who's got the
spirit of
Adventure I don't
know let's find out that's the fun isn't
it
so ah do I want to yeah sure what the
hell so
uh I had like in my
mind um I never had like a plot or a
plan or thing to do um but I just had
the general idea that if I were to ever
play the doctor in like a a fan work or
something that I wouldn't uh I wouldn't
try and do an English accent not because
I think I can't do one at all but
because I don't think I can maintain one
consistently uh enough not without a lot
of practice that I don't have time for
so in my mind um and like I emphasize
fan works I don't think you should cast
an American as the doctor in the main
show but you know fan works or fan works
is fine but in my mind the regener the
Regeneration starts it's like all right
what have we what what's the oh wait a
minute cup of
tea bollocks fish and chips oh it all
sounds wrong now and just being upset at
the American accent
so if I were the doctor that that's
that's how the Regeneration would kick
off and be completely unfazed by the um
to some people confusing nature of my
physical being some people very much
like my physical being there's another
place where you can go for fans who like
that sort of thing wow I put too much
meat in
here
[Music]
okay I think I think we're about to uh
to wrap it
up I speculate one of the reasons people
like Temple of Doom I'm with you is
because people can consider mam to be
one of the cooler villains I I mean I
guess he kind of comes out of no where
though like he just shows up out of
nowhere and starts ripping people's
hearts out it's I don't
know
uh I think yeah I think we're about
to wrap things up for the
stream have seen the drama with pow
world it's popcorn worthy I haven't I
know it's a thing it's video game drama
as my brain has not shown
interest uh I travel with the doctor in
a heartbeat even better now that the
Tardis is accessible to me the the
accessibility is lovely to
see Tuesday why am I not pronouncing it
Tuesday oh that's
good Oh that's oh that's good Parker
thank you for that
[Laughter]
one Dharma swooping in at the very end
all H the council and they who run the
meetings thank you very very much oh
come on I maintained an English accent
for 30 odd years yeah but you had a head
start you have home team
Advantage excuse me
okay so
um what's coming up tomorrow I will be
on Twitch
I haven't decided yet if I'm going to
play more of turnup boy Robs a Bank or
if I'm going to go back to balers Gate
3 I think I'm going to do some more of
turnup boy Robs a bank tomorrow morning
on Twitch 10:30 a.m. eastern standard
time um and then again on Friday um I
might go back to balers Gate 3 by then
tomorrow it's going to be turn it boy
though um and then Saturday Saturday's
video that one will be interesting
Saturday's video uh is going to be on
why YouTuber apologies always
suck and that is in fact available right
now to uh patreon supporters it's in
Early Access on the patreon so you want
to see that early you can I I'm actually
I've actually got stuff up early uh it's
been a little while since I've had it up
for more than a day or two early but it
it was over a full week on this one it's
been an early access so
um that's what's coming up in the
immediate so hope to see at least some
of you uh in the uh in the chat for
twitch tomorrow and hope to see a bunch
of you back here Saturday for the new
video so uh thank you very much thank
you for joining me take care of yourself
um and please remember that you are
beautiful you are valid you are
loved you are the council I'm just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is a germed a germed a
germed too much
me oh mavity Works
woo